stanton evans and he is one of the great
long-term long time leaders of the
conservative movement he's been with us
from the beginning and he still keeps
going
he's worked as an editor journalist
television and radio commentator and he
founded the national journalism center
he sir
m stanton evans served as chairman of
the american conservative union from
1971 to 77.
he has a new book out called
blacklisted by history the untold story
of senator joe mccarthy and his fight
against america's enemies
you know turning a proper name into a
verb is a sign of historical
significance but the verb to mccarthy i
think as mr evans is going to tell us is
historically inaccurate
mr evans
thank you very much um
it's a great honor to be here
with you folks and with phyllis
we go back
a few years
uh goldwater days and even before
and it's been a long road and
in many ways a bumpy one but one that
has been well worth traveling
and uh i'm glad to be here with phyllis
and you today
as the intro suggests i've been around a
while anyway um
and i know we want time for q a right so
yes we do 15 minutes and then 15 minutes
of questions
get it right in there uh on qui are
there mics or did you speak from where
you are when you questioned yeah well
okay
i i say that because i'm a little bit
hard uh
hearing a little deaf
when you get older
there are two bad things that happen to
you
one is your hearing starts to go
and
i forget what the other one is but
i'll probably think of it in a minute
i want to commend you guys for being
here
you have heard
i don't know if you know this this is an
all-star team
that
has spoken to you at this conference
these are the very
best people in congress this line up
without
any shadow of a doubt
and
what you heard is gonna
i hope help you
in your own thinking and in your own
careers
after you leave here
i commend you for being here
and
putting in these hours
on these serious matters
and
i'm always i teach still in college and
i
always tell my students that there is
more to life
than keeping up with the kardashians
what but that's not keeping up with them
is not easy i mean it takes a lot of
study to know what they're doing
i saw kim kardashian had condemned the
the zimmerman verdict and
she you know would know about that her
father was an attorney for o.j simpson
um
that's that's true
um
that's correct um
and then i remember that um
do you guys know do you follow katy
perry is she still popular you know katy
perry said a couple years ago that two
years ago that it was an outrage
that health care in america is not free
and i asked my students i said are katy
perry concerts
free they're not and
my friend of mine the dean of the
business school checked at that time
a ticket to a katy perry concert costs
83
and i said that's an outrage why should
i not be able to go to a kitty berry
concert for nothing
um
well not that i would go to a katy perry
concert but
it's the principle of it so anyway
uh
i am a bit of a contrarian in in many
ways i for example the only time that i
text
is when i'm driving
[Laughter]
actually if you know me like phyllis
knows i don't even know how to text
anyway so that's
but that is the principle of that too so
and so i i'm looking at some you know
you mentioned the mccarthy book i have a
new book out
called stalin secret agents that's
that's the new book
and
they're both kind of about the same
thing so there's nothing wrong with
lumping them together a bit
they're about a period of american
history that is very
uh
frequently in fact almost always
misrepresented in the history books that
you may have read in college or in high
school
and i've tried to look at the mccarthy
era joe mccarthy the
how many of you ever heard of senator
mccarthy mccarthyism
okay
how many have ever heard anything good
about senator mccarthy
i see no hands
that's typical and that's not your fault
it's it's the fault of my generations
we're not
getting the truth out there
the new book is about
uh other people aspects of that era the
so-called cold war now from your
standpoint this might as well be
the war of 1812 or something it's a long
time ago
but it's important to know this history
for a couple of reasons and to know it
correctly one is just to know
the truth is important
in its for its own sake
but also because
some of the things that happened back
then and
the way they are treated today
are relevant to more recent events
and i think we need to know
the history to begin with just to know
it but also to
apply it to the present
and one of the things that
a friend of mine told me i did not see
this myself back in 1994
was the 50th anniversary of d-day you
guys all heard about d-day the landing
at normandy when the american troops
went ashore in france
that's called d-day it's in 1944
and this has been commemorated on
television
in 1994 the 50th anniversary my friend
saw this
and was on a tv station in peoria
illinois or whatever wherever it was
and
the young lady reading the teleprompter
referred
talking about these events to world war
11.
and which suggested to me that maybe
we're not teaching history very well
um
but also that we're not teaching latin
um
although you would think that after all
these super bowls we know something
about roman numerals but apparently not
anyway so
what i've tried to do in these two books
is to
look at what actually happened as
opposed to what's in most of the
textbooks that are out there and
one reason that this was possible is
that the truth about all this stuff for
years was covered up and to some degree
it still is
however
with the passage of time we have had
access to the files of the fbi the
federal bureau of investigation
who were tracking the bad guys who were
trying to do us harm back in the 40s and
50s
this was all
covered up at the time
and to some extent still is but now we
have a pretty good picture of what went
on
and to capsule it very briefly because
the time is limited
essentially what was going on
how many of you ever seen these uh born
supremacy movies you ever seen these
things that
matt damon and
um or james bond movies movies of that
type of there's always some bad guy
that's trying to or a group of bad guys
trying to take over the world
and matt damon stops them
and well back then unfortunately we did
not have matt damon
back in the 40s and 50s which might have
been a blessing
i don't know but anyway and that's
another story and
we had plenty of bad guys however who
were trying to take over the world
just like in the movies
except it was real
and the main people standing in their
way of taking over the world
were americans
we were the problem from their
standpoint
and so what they did these people were
called communists and they were agents
of the soviet union
which had a game plan of conquering
country after country after country
we were the big barrier to their success
so that
the
bad guys were
trying to influence what we did and they
infiltrated our government
to do this and and to to affect our
policy to serve the cause of moscow
and that's what these books are about
they go into these records that are now
available from the fbi and elsewhere
showing what really happened
things that were not available 50 years
ago
there turns out were hundreds of these
agents in the us government
who were some of them were very famous
one was named alger hiss
uh he was convicted finally and sent to
prison
soviet agent but there were many many
more like him
and they did a lot of bad stuff that
helped deliver
country after country after country to
the control of the communists
poland
yugoslavia china these countries were
all
handed over to the communists in large
measure because of what these communists
and our own government were able to do
to affect our policy
so that's what these books are in part
about
now i can't tell you much more than that
except that one of the things that
happened at that time was
a kind of blindness on the part of the
authorities as to what was going on
a denial that
well it's not really a you know a
problem we don't need to worry about it
anybody that complains about it like joe
mccarthy or the house committee or not
american activities or phil schlafly or
stan evans or whoever they're just uh
they're witch hunting
uh they're they're just crying up a
danger that it's non-existent we know
now that the danger was existent and it
was very severe
but one of the part one of the aspects
of this blindness
was a
mindset which said
that just because someone is a member of
the communist party
that
so what he's just a member of the
communist party mere membership that's
called
and in obedience to that
thought communists were invited into the
government
and there was like an affirmative action
program for communists
uh in which they said we you know this
problem is government we don't have
enough communists in it and they brought
in more communists and this was
particularly intense during world war 11
uh when
the soviets were the soviet union was
our ally against the nazis
well that mindset and that blindness
exists today
and can be transposed today
to the problem of radical islam
and the problem of the danger to our
security posed by
fanatics who mean to destroy us
it's not communist but they are
equally dangerous in some ways more so
in some ways because of the ability to
blow up the world trade center and
things of that nature
and there's a blindness toward this and
i can't document this agreement but i
want to give you some example
the problem
we you know there's a big fight about
immigration
going on now i'm sure you know this i
bet jeff sessions talked about it when
he was there by the way there is a great
man jeff sessions
i'm very proud to know him
and the
uh immigration problem is also a
national security problem in addition to
other things
and one of the things that resulted in
of course you guys were just
kids when this happened when the
night the original 9 11 happened
was that all the people who were
involved in those bombings were
here on visas that were issued by our
government
to let them come into the country
and people haven't been realized well
how could they let these people into the
country
well the answer is because
the mindset was the same as as toward
the communists in world war ii i'm going
to read to you what some of the
questions from the visa application
online the state department this is not
a joke i'm not making it up
if i were most of these people from
saudi arabia
and they were asked questions
at that time in the visa
application process
to find out if they should be admitted
and they all were
and here are some of the questions that
are asked
do you seek to enter the united states
to engage in export control violations
subversive or terrorist activities
how would you answer that
are you a member or representative of a
terrorist organization
yes sir right here
are you
all right you're probably the tea party
that's where you are
[Laughter]
you wouldn't be in here if you were one
of the other kind uh
and here sorry here's one have you ever
participated in persecutions directed by
the nazi government of germany
now
how old are these people i mean um
i was a kid in world war 11 and so
i have
these people got to be 90 100 years old
and so
uh then let's say um or have you ever
participated in genocide
and then there are boxes check yes or no
yes or no
and
it's photographically reproducing
yourself anyway so
i go through yeah i said well yeah i'd
like to do some export control
violations
and yeah terrorism some some terrorism
yes
um
uh yeah i'm a member of al qaeda yes
um
i've ever participated in persecutions
well i was just a kid you know but yeah
i did
and and some genocide but you know i
didn't have any values back then yes yes
yes so i i checked yes as if anybody
would to these questions and then it
says this as for if i'm lying i'm dying
says
well a yes answer does not automatically
signify ineligibility for a visa
if you answered yes
you may be required to personally appear
before a consular officer so like yeah
you're a nazi and you're committed
genocide and you remember al qaeda we
need to talk
hello
by a clue
this is the same mindset of the
world war 11.
well they're just communists what's the
problem here just come on in guys and so
that's what we're dealing with and there
are many other examples i'll give you
one other example
mayor bloomberg of new york anybody from
new york
okay maybe you can tell me is mayor
bloomberg a real person
[Laughter]
he's like a character out of a tom wolf
novel or something
uh and anyway
back
in 2010 i'm going to wrap it up here i
don't get a q a
that
he was
uh
there was a times square bomber a guy
from pakistan
you have a car bomb in the middle of
times square
cooker no no no that's the boston
marathon oh no the times square had a
pressure did he ever pressure didn't go
off
well i'll be darned there you go well
anyway
you learn something every day uh anyway
it goes in there and and what he had
didn't work that's true
he was spotted by an alert hot dog
vendor which proves that the security
system is really working because
that's our first line of defense
hot dog vendors i think you know maybe
we should put 20 000 hot dog vendors
down the mexican border
maybe
maybe they would be able to stop this
problem
but anyway so
so the next uh
he gets and he goes to the airport he
tries to fly to dubai to go back to
pakistan and so
like two days later i was in new york
after that
and he's being interviewed by katie
couric
then of cbs here are two giant
intellects you know really coming
and so
and so
katie couric says well mayor bloomberg
what do you think motivated this person
why would he drive this car bomb in
times square and then try to escape to
pakistan what's going on here
and
he says probably somebody upset about
the health care bill
now are they having a health care
problem in pakistan is that what
about so that's the there's your mindset
and it can go on and on it's okay there
i'll wrap it up now and a little off
color here i apologize phyllis i know
you know sometimes i i get a little
risque
but
phyllis knows me too well and the
this was a story about a family where
there was kind of two sets of children
there were the teenage children and the
younger children
and as happens
you have younger siblings maybe you know
how this works the younger kids were
picking up
things from the teenagers and repeating
them trying to be cool
so and some of the stuff they picked up
was off color
and so one morning
the two little kids come downstairs
for breakfast and the father is serving
breakfast and he says to the little boy
what would you like to have for
breakfast
a little boy says
oh what the hell
i might as well have some cornflakes
and the father he reached out and he
slapped the kid right across the
mountain said
i don't want to hear that again in this
house if i hear that again you're going
to get worse and than this so never say
that again
and he turns to the little girl and says
now what would you like for breakfast
she said we can bet your ass and we'll
be corn flakes
[Laughter]
the moral of that story is if something
bad happens to you it's a good idea to
know the reason
my time is up i thank you for yours
okay q a a little bit yeah
any questions
i'll be going to mtsu this fall uh
dealing with the immigration idea and he
seemed to indicate that perhaps
reforming the immigration immigration
process excuse me would uh help with
some of the issues with muslims causing
terrorism inside the united states
especially since we have terrorists who
are walking in and say yes they're going
to be terrorists
what would you say in response to the
idea that the federal government cede
control of immigration and the borders
to the individual states
well i don't know if that idea
can pass constitutional muster because
what we've had is the federal government
contending that has preempted the field
and suing arizona which tried to do this
and i'm happy to be a native texans i
know something about these matters
and
the states i'm sure would do a much
better job
than the federal government is doing i
don't i don't know if you guys ever read
investors business daily you see that i
had a long piece in there yesterday
about this immigration bill
which is a disaster and must be defeated
but i can tell you that the states will
do a better job than the federal
government's journey because they're not
interested in doing them
anything else
all right any other
no other questions
no other questions
oh yes in the pink
this might be um slightly unrelated um
i'll introduce myself first i'm maddie
vanderbleek and i'm from hillsdale
college
um i have a question kind it's about
abraham lincoln
is it okay if i ask a question about
that
abraham lincoln are you up on abraham
lincoln
no i'm not okay
what do you want just a general
discussion of abraham lincoln no no it's
um
just when i was younger um i heard that
he was a big hero because he freed the
slaves and then when i got into higher
education like college and high school
they would say um he's actually a racist
and he only did it for political
motivation so i wondered
um about the accuracy and like why that
interpretation has changed well you've
got people he'll still know a lot more
about this than i do
larry iron knows a lot about lincoln
here go into i'm sorry larry yarn knows
a lot more about
lincoln than i do
but
i think there are some
remarks of lincoln on record that
reflect such
attitudes
i think the general critique of lincoln
and again remember i'm from texas
i'm a confederate
uh and so
we had other issues
with president lincoln
besides his language it was more his is
he was a little too proactive
uh from our standpoint but that's
another story altogether well it was
world war one after all world war one or
whatever it was
uh where
anybody else i don't want to go right
here down here down here
hi i'm spencer i go to the college of
william mary how is it different when
you're trying to
when someone has been
when history has declared someone to be
bad like joe mccarthy yeah and you're
and it's sort of uh inspirational to
side with the underdog and to say well
maybe he wasn't so bad after all but
what about people who are overrated in
history who we need to bring down to
where they belong like john f kennedy or
martin luther king or you know somebody
some of these people who are just
lionized by the left as prophets and
saints and nelson mandela i mean
how do we how how do we come across as
not being mean when we criticize these
heroes of the left
well it's a very difficult
question and
but you're right there are certain
taboos you just cannot criticize or take
franklin roosevelt
my second book is mostly about president
roosevelt
in the the the conferences at the end of
the war
uh and what he did basically giving away
half the world to joseph stalin
and i go into that in some detail
well this is where you don't say this
this is just not said and
certainly jack kennedy and phyllis and i
are we were there when all that was
going on
and in fact some of the stuff that's
happening today
in terms of what obama is doing
was done by the candidates
50
years ago
they're using the irs
to crack down on conservatives that was
done back then
trying to silence conservatives on radio
that was done back then
uh trying to
uh
stifle conservative opinion in any way
whatsoever was done back then under
kennedy and then under lyndon johnson
this is all
ignored
uh in the history books
and it needs to be
emphasized
all i can say is and you're talking to
somebody
i know a lot about fighting these fights
try writing a book about defending joe
mccarthy and see
how many uh you know dinners you get
invited to at the new york times uh or
how much your books get reviewed at the
new york times or the washington post
the answer is zero
and
that's just the way it is but that
should not stop
us you particularly your generation you
guys are the hope
uh you have
i don't have that many years left
uh you've got lots of years left to do
this stuff
but you need to do it
somebody needs to do it now again
i know about the kardashians
i know that
we have to pay attention to what they're
doing
and i know you probably don't emphasize
that probably enough
but in addition to knowing whether
kardashians
or storage wars
we've ever watched that one of my
favorites
but
in addition to those things those are
good we need to do this other stuff
and you can do it you've got the years
you've got the decades
and i'm hoping you will answer your own
question in
the next
couple of decades
i guess
thank you all very much you're a great
group
put you on the spot here but uh
representative tom cole what do you
what's on your summer reading list
well i'm reading